Film Courage: What comes first the budget
or the script?
John Paul Rice, movie producer: Script.
The script dictates the budget.
The script is your heart and soul, the spine
of the whole thing that you’re going to
build off of the foundation of everything
that you’re going to lay on top of it and
if you have money first and you’re writing
to the budget of that, I think your creativity
is paramount.
And the dealing within the realities of what
resources are available to you and then you
start talking about money and how you’re
going to fulfill that vision but if the vision
is coming from a monetary...me personally...I’ve
had more money on some of my other films,
didn’t mean I did a better job producing.
In fact my third film MOTHER’S RED DRESS,
I had more money than any of the other ones
and it was my worst job producing/
Film Courage: Why?
John: Because I thought that by having more
money to pay more money to each position and
person that was working on it I was just going
to get better talent and therefore I took
my better part of myself out of the equation
just that it was going to be solved by money.
And I learned a very valuable lesson on that.
We got the film done and everything was great
and it worked out fine but I saw dollars and
that I could get this kind of DP and it didn’t
translate into success for the project.
In fact the person that I brought on once
that DP left the project for another project
in the middle of shooting, I brought in somebody
else that had less equipment, less experience
and he did a fantastic job because his motivation
was correct.
So if you look at it from this standpoint,
if you have money and you’re going to pay
people right?
We all want to get paid and we’ve got to
work to live and all that but if that is the
focus first then I think that you’re doing
the opposite.
It’s like Okay we’ve got a marketing campaign
we can do now let’s find a script if that’s
the kind of content that we want to sell as
opposed to what comes from within.
Film Courage: Do you think you didn’t screen
the people properly because they were so ready
to take the paycheck that you didn’t see
the commitment in them?
John: I think it was a combination of that
and just thinking that maybe I was trying
to...I think I took my vigilance off and not
qualifying people a level...I had a great
time working with all of those individuals
but I could have avoided a lot of problems
had I done better vetting of my cast and my
crew.
That’s not to say I regret any of it because
it was a learning experience and we got a
film done and we did a really good job with
it and it impacted a lot of people but in
terms of my job as a producer, I stepped away
from certain things and just figured they
were going to take care of themselves because
I had more money, that was a mistake I made.